وقال وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي اكار بين
ضربات الجويه 30 فدتها القوات التركيه على
مواقع في منطق عين العرب شمال الشرقيه
سوريا وفي شمال العراق نجحت في تدمير
مواقع
ومقر لحزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه التي وصفهاما
بالمنظمات الارهابيه
التي تعود الارهابيين وتعقبنا ذلك عن كذب
وتم تدمير مقر تابعي للمنظمه الارهابيه
كما تم استهدافه الارهابيين والمواقع التي
تخصهم فقط ومخلب القوات المسلحه
الارهابيين مره اخرى ولدينا القدره
والاصرار على انقاذ بلدنا وشعبنا من بلاء
الارهاب المتسلط عليهم منذ 40 عاما ولم
نترك ابدا تقرا شهدائنا ومواطنين الابرياء
ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر محليه ان
القصف طال مواقع عسكريه لما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في تل رفعت وعين دقنه
برفي حلب وشمال عين عيسى في ريف الرقه
ومناطق في الحسكه وعين العرب كوباني على
الحدود السوريه التركيه في المقابل نقلت
رويترز عن متحدث باسم ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه التي تشكل وحدات وحدات الشعب
الكرديه عمودها الفقري ان طائرات تركيه
قصفت قريتين ماهولتين بالنازحين في شمال
سوريا كما نقلت وكاله الانباء السوريه
الرسميه عن مصدر عسكريا مقتل عدد من
الجنود اثر الهجمات التركيه على ريفي حلب
والحسك